à cause des trafics de drogue le campus
d'une fac devait fermer à Marseille
depuis mercredi des CRS ont été envoyés
en renfort des effectifs locaux on
entend beaucoup crier en bas laab laab
laab ou bien même quand on sent qu'il y
a des personnes qui sont pas apprécié
d'ê venu ici on entend beaucoup bah ça
prévient quoi c'est on soncentrit en
cour c'est pas toujours facile ça se
passe à la Faculté d'économie et de
gestion du site Colbert situé à
proximité du vieux port à partir de ce
vendredi après les cours et jusqu'au 13
octobre l'accès au campus devait être
fermé les cours devaient donc être
assurés en distantiel et les personnels
redéployés ou en télétravail 1500
étudiants et une cinquantaine de
personnels étaient concernés mais
finalement jeudi après une réunion avec
la préfecture de police et la mairie
l'université a annoncé qu'elle restera
ouverte mais avec la présence permanente
de policiers selon les personnels la
situation ne cesse de se dégrader avec
l'apparition de points de deal de drogue
qui attire de nombreux toxicomanes mardi
la préfecture de police a bien reconnu
une dégradation de la situation dans le
quartier cololbert elle a aussi indiqué
qu'une opération d'enlèvement de pote
d'î avait eu lieu une semaine plus tôt
dans un autre quartier de la ville des
policiers ont été déployés près d'une
école élémentaire et aussi toute proche
d'un point deal à 1h30 de là à nî début
juin c'est le maire Jean-Paul Fournier
qui avait pris la décision de fermer
jusqu'à nouvel ordre la médiathèque Marc
Bernard un des derniers services publics
du quartier pauvre de pisevin c'est au
pied de ces bares d'immeubl que deux
personnes dont un enfant de 10 ans
atteint d'une balle perdue sont décédés
fin août dans des violences liées au
trafic de
stupéfiants